everyone it's the cosmic blender here
The Avengers Ford trailer just came out
I have not seen it yet it came out of
literally not gonna waste any time we're
just gonna get right into it here we go
I'm watching it for the very first time
[Music]
I remain sound that
hey responsible if you find this
recording the mallanna don't fit better
at this
if I were no stand
just there could be the drift is space
for zero promise of rescue is more fun
that sounds where doesn't that be able
to foot water went out for days to come
boxers pop out tomorrow morning
where's nebula when I just off I will
join Beth you oh [ __ ]
don't do it don't do it oh you turned it
off they tested the logo
Bannos don't run the Scarecrow drop my
skill damage when he still damaged
50% blonde hair stone creatures
I think Scott's dead how would they know
we lost the horse oh there's nothing
left to look like she's nauseous
[Music]
Ronen lost part of ourselves you have
grown and hot guy look around is the
fight of our lives
thank you time travel this is good work
Steve what's gonna work do we get the
title
the system vendors
it's just Avengers
so it's gone oh wait in game in game
four the first thing I said is gonna be
they think he's dead
message I think he's dead
April
they changed the day it used to be May
they changed the day oh my gosh that's
coming a little sooner oh my gosh that
was insane it was definitely just a
teaser trailer but I'm going to go
record a breakdown video for everybody
right now thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]